رسائل متضاربة تصدر من واشنطن
خاصة من الرئيس ودقيقة واحدة
يتحدث عن الحرب قائلاً إنه
إذا أرادت إيران القتال ، فستكون هذه هي
النهاية الرسمية لإيران ، ثم في المرة التالية
يخفف من حدة التوتر قائلاً إنه لا توجد
دلائل على قيام طهران باتخاذ إجراء
ما.  هي استراتيجية دونالد ترامب ، إذا
فاز بالفعل ، أعتقد بالتأكيد أن
الاستراتيجية هي حملة الضغط الأقصى
التي تستخدم جميع عناصر القوة الوطنية الأمريكية
والمعلومات السياسية الدبلوماسية وحتى العسكرية لحمل
إيران على العودة إلى طاولة المفاوضات
الآن ، وهذا لا يعني أن  نحن
يتطلع إلى بدء حرب في الواقع إذا
نظرت إلى الولايات المتحدة.  الموقف وحتى
خطابنا حتى كيف قرأت ، ربما
يتطلع إلى وقف الجائزة ، لذلك أعتقد
أنه في هذا
السياق ، أعتقد أن الرئيس يواجه
مشكلة الجمهور حيث
يريد بالطبع أن يخفف من حدته في الجانب الأمريكي  أي مخاوف من
احتمال حدوث صراع ، ومن
الجانب الإيراني يريد التأكد من
أن هذه العقوبات المتزايدة ، وهذا
التمركز العسكري المتزايد في
المنطقة ، يؤخذ على محمل الجد ، لكن
المشكلة هي أن الإيرانيين يدركون
ما يقوله الرئيس
للجمهور المحلي.  هنا ويمكن أن يؤدي ذلك في
الوقت الإضافي إلى تقويض فعالية
ردعنا ، لذا فأنت تعتقد أن دونالد
ترامب لا يريد الحرب لأنه
يبدو أن إدارته منقسمة قليلاً ،
فقد دعا مستشار الأمن القومي
جون بولتون منذ فترة طويلة إلى
تغيير النظام في إيران ولكنك  تعتقد أن
دونالد ترامب لا يريد حربًا
صحيحة الآن إذا نظرت إلى سياسة الولايات المتحدة
تجاه إيران ، فهي تتعامل تمامًا مع
السياسة الخارجية والأمنية للنظام.
في الخارج القريب بالإضافة إلى
مجالات التهديد الوظيفية الرئيسية مثل البرنامج النووي
أو البرنامج السيبراني مع
برنامج الصواريخ ، كل هذه الأمور لها علاقة
بسلوك النظام الآن في الواقع ، في
الواقع ، يتعين على الإدارة أن
تكون قادرة على الزواج من بعض خطاباتها
لدعم الشعب الإيراني الذي
كان مثيرًا للإعجاب ببعض
الإجراءات الأخرى ولكن لا يعد هذا نهجًا صارمًا
لتغيير السلوك من وجهة نظري